alité de preuves par 3 françois rebsamen
le président du groupe des sénateurs
socialistes et un proche de françois
hollande
bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec nous
car il perd et de la régence
france-presse notre partenariat avec
dailymotion et perrine tarneaud de
public sénat
nous rejoindrons tout à l'heure au cours
de cette émission bien sûr qui abordera
et bien les difficultés de l'action
gouvernementale souligne édith on part
avec des parlementaires ps et même on
verra si vous faites de même ce soit
avec nous françois rebsamen ont coincé
flottement de l'exécutif sur les roms
sur la pause fiscale sur le travail le
dimanche répond une surenchère des
attaques de la droite qui fait feu de
tout bois notamment sur les nouveaux
rythmes scolaires tiens à propos ceux ci
sont entrées en vigueur dans votre ville
de dijon vous avez fait ce choix à la
dernière rentrée
est ce que vous faites le même bilan
désastreux que les parents d'élèves
n'ont en tous les cas pas dix jours je
peux pas généraliser mais ce que je sais
c'est qu'à dijon la rentrée s'est bien
passée
elle s'est bien passé pour plusieurs
raisons premièrement parce que le
gouvernement a remis des postes dans
l'éducation nationale
il faut le rappeler c'est la première
fois depuis 1985 qu'a dit jean hily à
des ouvertures de classes avec un nombre
d'élèves qui augmente donc ça facilite
bien sûr la rentrée et les rythmes et
les rythmes et les rythmes sont mis en
place et ça fonctionne bien nous venons
d'en faire un point bilan hier soir au
conseil municipal de dijon et nous avons
constaté que dans toutes les écoles où
ses rythmes ans était mis en place ça se
passe bien vous faites mieux que partout
ailleurs quoi indigents non mais
peut-être peut-être ça se passe bien
jean-françois copé président de l'ump
considère que cette réforme appliquée à
la hâte mais l'école à feu et à sang
mais ça c'est du cope dans le texte
pourquoi je vous dis ça parce que quand
jean françois copé et le gouvernement de
nicolas sarkozy ont décidé de revenir à
la semaine de quatre jours sans prévenir
personne
on l'a appris par une dépêche afp un
matin et qu'il a fallu que toutes les
communes s'organisent pour faire ce
qu'on appelle l'accueil de loisirs sans
le mercredi matin ça a coûté beaucoup
d'argent aux communes on s'est pas posé
la question à ce moment là et nous ce
qu'on fait aujourd'hui c'est un constat
d'échec de cette loi de la semaine de
quatre jours et parce que ce qu'on veut
mettre au coeur des choses c'est l'élève
et pour l'élève le rythme scolaire le
qui est prônée par les chronobiologistes
par tous ceux qui suivent ceux là qui se
constatent d'ailleurs parent comment
dire à un recul de plus en plus
important depuis six ou sept ans des
capacités d'acquisition des
connaissances fondamentales lire écrire
compter
et bien et du un rythme de surcharge
d'une journée est donc aujourd'hui les
activités périscolaires notamment en
maternelle
ils sont pas plus fatigué at il dit sont
là les petits mais produire un réseau
surchargé izon parce que nous on a un
programme éducatif territorial qui
remplace depuis longtemps on a préparé
tout cela et dans ce temps qu'on appelle
le temps périscolaire c'est à dire 1
après le temps de l'éducation nationale
ils ont des activités d'éveil des
activités ludiques encadrées par atos
passe bien chez mory et sur le plan
financier ça se passe ainsi pour pour
notre commune
elle sait pas trop lourd non c'est non
c'est pas trop lourd
d'abord on est aidé par le fonds
d'amorçage du gouvernement ensuite on a
aidé par les aides de la caf qui a de la
caisse d'allocations familiales qui
abondent les aides du gouvernement
quand il ya un vrai programme éducatif
local ce qui est notre cas vous avez vu
françois rebsamen que beaucoup de vos
collègues socialistes en d'autres
grandes villes ont préféré attendre là
je pense à gérard collomb à lyon as
martine aubry à lille ils ont été
prudents et réalistes
peut-être la situation dans ces communes
là moi je me permets pas de porter
jugement
j'étais avec gérard collomb il ya
quelques minutes
il me demandait comment ça se passait à
dijon et je lui disais comment ça c'est
vrai par ailleurs encouragé à prendre le
train en marche à la prochaine rentrée
assure qu est ce qui peut éviter au
parti socialiste un vote sanction aux
prochaines municipales et là on quitte
un président intentions d'accor
on en a on y reviendra plus et non non
mais je ne parlais pas je ne vais pas
répondre
dijon à votre question qu'est ce qui
peut éviter à votre sens de la qualité
du travail fourni par nos mères j'irai
même plus loin voyez pour la première
fois je veux dire par les maires en
général les maires sont aujourd'hui
apprécié dans la majorité des cas bien
apprécié et très apprécié par quelle que
soit leur étiquette je veux dire qu'en
général les maires elle se legault gère
mieux je le dire avec un sourire tout le
monde comprendra bien sûr mais les
maires en général font bien leur travail
sont appréciés je pense que ça se
traduira quand même dans les élections
municipales
vous ne pensez ça sera un facteur de
résistance pour les menus socialiste et
sortant il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'inquiétude car nenê et vous permettez
c'est un facteur de résistance et la
proximité de ces élus avec les habitants
des villes est aussi un facteur de
résistance à la montée des extrêmes
alors il est beaucoup d'inquiétude
néanmoins parmi les élus locaux parmi
les parlementaires ps également ces
derniers entendent améliorer le budget
qui vient en discussion en faveur du
pouvoir d'achat
et certains à la gauche du ps en main
mais jusqu'à demander que l'on renonce à
augmenter la tva le 1er janvier prochain
est ce que vous vous soutenez cette idée
non des décisions ont été prises elles
ont été votées d'ailleurs par ces mêmes
parlementaires
il faut maintenant qu'ils soient en
conformité avec leur propre vote donc on
n'est pas là dans le concours lépine des
propositions fiscales
la ligne du gouvernement est claire il
faut redresser les comptes publics de la
france
faut-il rappeler là et là il faut aider
la compétitivité des entreprises
justement si on peut ne plus souhaiter à
partir de poule mais j'en ai c'est pour
financer le crédit auto compétitive des
monnaies entre un coût des entreprises
donc la position est simple et en même
temps difficile à tenir elle est simple
à expliquer nous sommes sur une ligne de
crête
la ligne de crête c'est le chemin que
nous devons suivre pour redresser les
comptes de la france pour préserver
l'emploi et pour se préparer à la
reprise de la croissance
de l'autre côté il ya le versant de plus
de rigueur plus de rigueur plus de
rigueur
ça amène à une politique d'austérité
renforcé et de l'autre côté il y à
l'autre versant c'est il faut relâcher
l'effort il faudra distribués et ça
amène exactement le résultat est
la décision la ligne voulue par françois
hollande c'est cette ligne au milieu qui
permet dans la justice tout à la fois
redresser les comptes
progressivement ce que vous savez moi je
vous renvoie toujours aux entreprises la
politique de l'entreprise une fois où il
faut c'est simple à expliquer mon
impression que ce n'est pas toujours
simple à assumer oui c'est pas facile
sur une étude c'est vrai c'est pas
facile à assumer parce que la tradition
veut que la gauche soit redistributrice
or il est clair aujourd'hui que quand on
arrive au pouvoir il faut que les
parlementaires socialistes se le dise
quand on arrive au pouvoir après dix ans
de droite c'est que la droite a
profondément échoué et que l'état de
notre pays ne nous permet pas de mener
une politique de redistribution n'est
pas facile à assumer
ce renoncement à cette politique de
distribution en attendant des jours
meilleurs
c'est une nécessité aujourd'hui attendre
d'avoir une politique l'an de l'offre
parce que notre appareil productif a été
profondément profondément détruit sept
cent cinquante mille emplois industriels
wemhoff puis les gens depuis 10 mai
quand vous dites c'est difficile à
suivre une politique de relance
aujourd'hui amènerait une l'austérité
renforcé quand vous dites c'est
difficile à assumer pour le chef de
l'état d'abord oui pour la gauche on
l'expliqué il faut expliquer les choses
il faut expliquer pourquoi on est obligé
de mener cette politique que les fruits
de cette politique prenne du temps parce
que on veut préserver justement et
l'emploi et la croissance ce qui revient
et donc pour faire cela il faut attendre
un peu
andré parpaings permettez moi cette
formule un peu lapidaire on ne répare
pas en 18 mois ce qui a été abîmé en
disant vous dit c'est pas le concours
lépine sur le plan fiscal mais quand
même il ya des propositions qui vont lui
scellant le mans terre socialiste vous
peut-être en attendait coup de pouce ils
sont annoncés d'ailleurs on dit que les
parlementaires ont l'oreille de bercy
par exemple est-ce qu'il faut renoncer à
abaisser la tva sur les produits de
première nécessité pour augmenter par
exemple la prime pour l'emploi qu'en
dites vous c'est la marge de manoeuvre
que ce garde les parlementaires
socialistes ils ont raison ils ont la
possibilité de discuter du texte que
présente le gouvernement à la marge à la
marge libyen à la marge et s'ils ont des
propositions et j'en doute pas
intelligente a formulé elles peuvent
être prises à la rue dit
faut assumer la politique qui est suivi
un décidée par le chef de l'état un mot
sur les retraites puisqu'on a appris
aujourd'hui que le document envoyé par
la france à bruxelles pour définir mais
comme il est prévu maintenant sa
stratégie de politique économique qui
reconnaît cela document officiel de
paris reconnaît que l'âge de départ à la
retraite va faire un bond après
l'allongement à 43 ans la durée de
cotisation donc l'âge légal reste
officiellement à 62 ans mais l'âge réel
en fait pour partir avec une retraite à
taux plein eh bien ce sera de 66 ans et
ça c'est écrit noir sur blanc pourquoi
ne pas assumer à paris ce que l'on dit à
bruxelles françois rebsamen pas mélanger
michel grossiord les choses le départ
officiel de possibilité de partir à la
retraite à 62 ans avec nous avons avec
une pension critique qui j'y viens j'y
viens nous avons décidé d'allonger
progressivement à partir de 2020 la
durée de cotisation qui passera de
quarante et une années annuités ennemis
à 43 annexes en 2030 en 2030
effectivement si l'âge moyen d'entrée
dans la vie active et de 23 ans
ceux qui auront cotisé 43 ans auront une
retraite à taux plein à 67 ans en 2030
mais nous avons pris un certain nombre
de mesures pour remédier cela et il faut
le rappeler le
la possibilité de prendre en compte la
pénibilité des des travaux qui permet de
racheter des trimestres pour les
étudiants et pour les jeunes
il en est de même avec la possibilité de
racheter des trimestres et donc soixante
six ans en 2030 ça sera le maximum quand
on aura regardé ce qui a été fait pour
la pénibilité et pour les jeunes rentrer
plus tard dans la vie active on
s'apercevra ça sera pas la généralité
passera par la généralité on dit
aujourd'hui que la france est sur deux
peu par rapport à partir avant 62 ans
le problème aujourd'hui essentiel vous
le savez d'ailleurs très bien c'est pas
un jeu à laquelle ils peuvent partir à
la retraite c'est la possibilité de
travailler jusqu'à la retraite pour les
personnes qui sont d'ailleurs les plus
âgés dans l'entreprise parce qu'elles
peuvent elles perdent leur emploi bien
souvent ça comme cinq ans 57m 58s que
vous avez compris le flottement du
gouvernement sur le travail le dimanche
en temporis parce que les ministres ne
sont pas tous d'accord et on revit
rendez vous dans deux dans deux mois
pourtant aussi on le connaît retranché à
droite décider la droite n'a pas pu le
régler vous le savez bien
luc chatel que j'écoutais dernièrement
reconnaissait qu'il avait fait une loi
qui n'était pas ce qu'il fallait faire
donc il faut qu'on modifie cette loi
donc il faut trouver pour rappeler les
principes le repos dominical reste un
principe faut rappeler quand même que
près de 30% des salariés travaillent le
dimanche
dans les emplois de la sécurité les
transports de l'hôtellerie de la
restauration etc des occasionnels ment
beaucoup occasionnellement c'est vrai
enfin de sécurité c'est quand même elle
dans la santé c'est souvent le dimanche
et puis il faut donner un peu de
souplesse je pense que ce sera la
profession la même position que fera
monsieur bailly puisque il va faire des
propositions d'ici six semaines ça va
aller vite faut de la souplesse je pense
pour les zones touristiques
il faut de la souplesse pour ces zones
d'urbanisme commercial qui sont des
zones absolue est exceptionnel dans un
certain nombre de villes
il ya là les voilà les qualités de la
souplesse qu'il faut avoir il faut
toujours avoir un souci de préserver les
salariés l'emploi salarié est ce que
vous me permettez encore 12 noms de
remarques
là où ça a été libéralisé totalement ce
que j'ai regardé cela que ce soit en
italie
que ce soit en espagne où la
libéralisation était totale du travail
du dimanche
ça a été une destruction d'emplois
massifs dans le petit commerce
nous on ne veut pas de cela d'accord un
député socialiste dénonce les ministres
qui se comportent dit-il en enfants
gâtés de la république le gouvernement
c'est l'équipe de france de nice n'a dit
il en référence à la coupe du monde en
afrique du sud
et c'est signé jean christophe
cambadélis est ce que vous êtes d'accord
avec sa vision je veux le dire autrement
dire qu'il faut un peu plus de sens
collectif
voilà c'est le foot oui il faut jouer
collectivement c'est à dire qu'il faut
pas essayer de tirer la couverture à soi
pour se mettre en valeur
on est dans une ambition collective
celle de redresser la france et nous le
faisons que le prix d'un public donc on
doit être respectueux de la fonction
qu'on a c'est une occasion pour moi de
le dire à tous les mises jouer collectif
jusqu'à la prochaine fois
oui mais vous savez il ya dans le
gouvernement des personnalités
ils ont le droit aussi le s'exprimer
mais elles n'ont pas le droit de rompre
l'engagement collectif mais si on suit
jean christophe cambadélis françois
hollande ce soir raymond domenech alors
non je ne pense pas je voudrais pas
mettre en cause vraiment de mener on va
parler de l'autorité du chef de l'état
certains lui reprochent à nouveau
aujourd'hui de ne pas assumer certaines
de ses décisions sa vie politique et
surtout son autorité ces critiques ont
resurgi avec le bras de fer évidemment
entre cécile duflot et manuel valls on
va en parler dans un instant ce que ce
procès totalement infondées il est il
est infondée président de la république
est quelqu'un qui a de l'autorité qui
s'est décidée quand il faut décider on
l'a vu à l'occasion des crises
internationales à l'international parce
que les sols et perrin vous dire qu'à
l'international il le seul à décider
c'est simple c'est son pouvoir il le
chef des armées
il décide donc cet homme c'est décidé et
à l'intérieur d'une société qui a été je
vais vous faire l'analyse de françois
hollande qui était profondément
traumatisé par 50 sarkozysme où on a
opposés les uns aux autres son souci est
de rassembler et de rassembler les
français pour les rassembler il a une
politique
une méthode qui est différente de celle
de nicolas sarkozy et donc il n'est pas
pour trancher dans le vif tous les jours
tous les matins tous les sujets il
s'exprimait à matignon des ministres et
a oui je vois mais il s'attendait pas
être populaire s'il est impopulaire
aujourd'hui et il est je ne le nie pas
bien évidemment s'il est impopulaire
c'est à cause de la situation économique
et donc sa cote se redressera avec la
baisse du chômage
en espérant que les pas de trafic que de
se faire sur les chiffres ont parlé
sa cote se redressera avec cela que la
france qui sera
vous nous livrez l'analyse de françois
hollande et vous nous dites qu'il est
tranquille inoxydable oui serein
inoxydable bien évidemment sensible à
l'impatience l'impatience des français
qui hélas oui bien sûr parce que c'est
difficile de dire aux français nous je
vous demande encore de faire des efforts
fait des efforts supplémentaires mais ça
va prendre du temps ça prend du temps
c'est vrai alors le seconde dans le
manque d'esprit collectif comme venue de
françois rebsamen a été atteint
évidemment par manuel valls et cécile
duflot sur les roms un débat que le
premier ministre tranche à sa manière en
disant que l'intégration est possible si
les lois sont respectées avant
d'accueillir catherine perret de l'
agence france presse jérôme brodier nous
présente l'offensive tous azimuts du
ministre de l'intérieur 12 d'ailleurs à
beaucoup d'élus locaux en prévision des
municipales comme une majorité de
français d'ailleurs les sondages le
montrent là il est le ministre préféré
des français
et pourtant il déclenche la polémique
jusque dans sa propre majorité
moins de six mois avant les élections
municipales manuel valls et déjà
pourtant très sollicité par les
candidats socialistes à ces élections
cette politique juste et efficace si
elle est si bien perçue par l'ensemble
des maires dans l'ensemble des
territoires de france c'est parce
qu'elle correspond à une réalité ces
élus locaux ont d'ailleurs publié une
tribune ce week-end pour soutenir son
action car dans leur municipalité
ils peuvent parfois se retrouver
confronté à des campements illicites et
à l'exaspération de leurs administrés
manuel valls répond aujourd'hui à la
demande des élus comme moi quand au bout
des procédures judiciaires il y à
l'exécution des décisions de justice à
mettre en oeuvre donc avec la force
publique
donc il fait tout simplement il assume
ses responsabilités de ministre de
l'intérieur
mais ce discours qui se veut ferme mais
également de nombreuses voix dans la
majorité qui préférerait que d'autres
thèmes soient mises en avant dans la
campagne qui commence comme et admettre
qu'on est en plein drame
par contre comme iliad merco des
problèmes de chômage dans leur
territoire
bien sûr entamèrent à des problèmes de
comment faut traiter le problème il faut
mettre en oeuvre la circulaire pas
besoin d'aller claironner partout dans
la france entière pour vingt mille
personnes
donc bien sûr que les élus ont besoin
d'être entendus et pas seulement avant
les municipales
roux les partis politiques cherchent la
réponse au front national la droite
soutient les propos de manuel valls tout
en critiquant son action bien consciente
qu'il représente une gauche qui ne veut
plus laisser le thème de la sécurité à
la droite
nous nous disons la même chose que lui
sauf que nous nous réaliserions des
choses concrètement et que lui pour le
mans ne peut pas à les réaliser il n'y a
pas de raison qui nous gêne à droite on
est tenté de dire chiche fait le
refusant de le rappeler à l'ordre comme
cécile duflot le lui demandait françois
hollande confirme qu'il compte sur son
ministre de l'intérieur pour monter au
front sur ce sujet qui ne risque pas de
retomber avant les prochaines échéances
électorales
dimanche il ya eu un texte de soutien de
ses élus soutien à manuel valls qui
considère que son action contre les
campements illicites de roms est tout à
fait fondée ce texte vous signez j'ai
pas vu votre signature
moi je suis jeune et j'ai pas de
problème bien sûr que l'action de manuel
valls est tout à fait fondée quand ils
démentaient le des campements de roms
ceux à qui sont en situation
d'illégalité qui occupe indûment des
terrains privés
bien sûr ils appliquent la loi
républicaine et il a raison est-ce que
vous pensez que manuel valls a mis en
cause justement le pacte républicain
comme l'a dit sa collègue du
gouvernement cécile duflot je pense que
pour la situation des roms dans notre
pays
la ligne juste la bonne ligne c'est
celle de la circulaire du mois d'août
2012 c'est à dire il faut la fermeté la
plus républicaine la plus républicaine à
l'égard de ceux qui aujourd'hui sont
dans l'illégalité et donc il faut
démanteler les campements de roms
voilà et quitte à renvoyer dans leur
pays ce qui alimente les réseaux mafieux
parce qu'il y en a un retour de ces
campements bien souvent ceux qui
pratiquent qui ne respectent pas les
lois de la république
mais l'autre côté je voudrais le dire
ici c'est que pour ceux qui souhaitent
sincères et il faut les aider à
l'insertion walid il ya un postulat qui
a été annoncé par le ministre de
l'intérieur considère
dans leur immense majorité les roms ne
peuvent pas à s'intégrer
alors là ont signé là aussi comme un
texte de soutien je ne dirais pas les
choses comme ça je dois vous signez pas
je ne dirais pas les choses comme ça je
dirais qu'une grande majorité
une grande majorité de rome c'est vrai
ne veulent pas s'intégrer mais je ne
dirais pas que tous les roms ne veulent
pas s'intégrer et donc ceux qui hésitent
ou s'il a dit bon majorité bons mots si
c'est l'immense majorité c'est vrai
qu'une grande majorité allemands sous
grande majorité une grande majorité sont
prêts je le crois ça sert et à condition
qu'on leur donne les moyens d'insertion
dans cette histoire en attendant que
françois hollande tranche aujourd'hui on
a entendu jean marc ayrault qui disait
que l'intégration était possible donc il
ya une contradiction entre le premier
ministre et son ministre de l'intérieur
qui livre est bon mais manuel valls il
n'est pas chargé de l'insertion des
populations immigrées
il est chargé de faire appliquer la loi
républicaine quand il ya égalité de
campements roms tous les matins il ya
des mères qui l'appelle pour lui
demander de démanteler des campements
roms
donc il le fait dans la mesure des
possibilités quand on en a une décision
de justice et qu'il applique la décision
de justice
il ya aux portes de paris comment en
nous pour le moment on peut pas obtenir
des sillons de justice parce que les
terrains appartiennent multipropriété
donc c'est difficile parce qu'il faut
que le propriétaire du terrain demande
lui-même l'évacuation
donc quand il le fait dans le cas de la
loi républicaine avec fermeté et
humanité
moi je soutiens totalement manuel valls
mais je dis que quand des familles roms
souhaitent s'insérer dans notre pays on
doit les aider à la série comment ça se
mesure ça c'est une volonté
d'intégration seulement dans votre ville
à dijon vous avez un village d'insertion
depuis quelques mois comment ça se passe
comment on pouvait bien se passe très
bien
il y avait une grosse gros campement
une minorité a souhaité à ses récents
des familles avec enfants les enfants
sont scolarisés et nous accompagnons ces
familles qui souhaitent s'insérer dans
notre camp ils l'ont exprimé sur tous
les i c'est souvent des familles vous
savez on repère assez vite dans les
campements roms ce qu'ils sont ce qu'on
appelle à la tête de réseau qui font
mendier les femmes qui empêche les
enfants déscolarisés et donc pour cela
excusez moi de l'expression pas de pitié
à voir ne respectent pas la loi
républicaine et quand des familles de
bonne foi mais elles sincères et il faut
les aider alfano
enfin les insérer saine et sauve et de
l'âme
mais groupes mafieux oui bien sûr c'est
les sortir c'est les sortir de la misère
c'est leur donner des conditions de vie
décentes
comme on le doit à toute personne
surtout quand il ya des enfants
scolarisés les enfants s'est accompagnée
pas de l'assistanat social ces familles
c'est ce que nous faisons a dit jean je
ne donne pas des gens forcément un
exemple ça se passe bien mais c'est vrai
ce que dit manuel est juste mais elle va
cependant les justes et comprises à une
grande majorité ne veut pas sincères et
ça c'est clair
les écologistes ce sont des alliés
difficile vous l'avez vu senna ils ont
reproduit certains dérouter certains
textes
est ce que comme un certain nombre de
membres du gouvernement vous jugé qu' il
y en a marre des écologistes
ça commence à bien commence à bien faire
ce qu'ils sont à voulait non c'est pas
sympa boulet c'est un partenaire les
écologistes sur les partenaires les
partenaires je n'emploierai pas le mot
turbulent c'est des partenaires qui
parfois sont agaçants ils sont adjacents
pour la majorité mais sont agaçants pour
eux même s'ils se regarde bien c'est à
dire qu' il faut que il ramène aussi de
l'ordre chez eux
il faut qu'ils arrêtent de tourner mais
pour le moment sur les textes essentiels
le soutien au budget parce que c'est
quand même la pts majeur les écologistes
ont toujours été là maintenant faut
qu'ils remettent aussi un peu d'ordre
dans la maison écologie ça c'est clair
mais est ce qu'une ministre peut en
appeler comme ça publiquement à
l'arbitrage de françois hollande alors
qu'il est ce jour-là à florange ça lui
gâche complètement sa journée il
essayait de se rabibocher avec les
salariés les syndicats
est-ce que vous qui êtes un proche de
l'état vous confirmer que électret c'est
parce qu'il lui a plu le plus ce jour là
oui il était heureux de montrer sa
capacité à aller à nouveau dialoguer
avec eux les salles à florange et
d'ailleurs il n'a pas donné de réponse à
cette interpellation
justement ça ce que certains lui
reprochent ses prêts de conséquence
pinard y était furieux mais ça n'a pas
été aussi bonne
auteur de la phrase il ne répond pas un
crime elle ou de l'interpellation il va
pas répondre les agents fonctions du
président de la république il dira ce
qui l'a énormément venu mais c'est
pathétique parce que il n'ya pas il n'y
a pas de réponse la seule réponse c'est
finalement pascal durand qui va partir
de la tête du parti et puis c'est tout
le parti écologiste qui se gère à sa
manière c'est pas un mot n'a rien à y
voir de l'andra gestion du mais ça me
permet de leur demander de mettre un peu
d'ordre dans leurs propres maisons
connaître que ce sont des partenaires
turbulent quand il a porté à la majorité
présidentielle
il apporte une vision de la gauche qui
est une vision importante
maintenant ils peuvent gâcher assez vite
par des prises de positions qui sont
contradictoires on va dire par des
prises de position leur capital
électoral de sympathie on a vu ce qui
s'est passé avec les groenen en
allemagne où il avait commencé très haut
ils sont en train de descendre donc je
suis les appels pour eux d'ailleurs pour
nous pour la gauche a retrouvé leurs
esprits à être unis vous apprendrez par
exemple toutes les initiatives de la
ministre du logement vous êtes maire de
dijon vous suis très près le dossier de
l'immobilier par exemple est ce que vous
pensez ce que sa loi
est favorable au prolongement oui je la
soutiens ah oui je la soutiens je la
soutiens on apportera des améliorations
bien sûr mais je soutiens la première
loi qu'elle avait présentés mais fait
d'ailleurs d'écouter cet égard des
sénateurs sur les suites de la loi
puisque j'ai eu un problème
constitutionnel mais il y a
aujourd'hui dans la loi à lui requis la
nouvelle loi sur le logement qu'elle
présente tout un tas de dispositifs qui
ont été étudiées qui vont être étudiées
qui sont étudiées en ce moment par les
sénateurs qui correspondent à ce qu'on
attend on a besoin dans ce pays de
construire des logements locatifs à
loyer modéré elle fait tout pour que ça
se passe bien elle est donc une bonne
ministre du logement dans sa fonction de
ministre du logement
oui parce que finalement le malheur de
françois hollande dans la gestion du
quotidien avec les écologistes c'est pas
cet accord de mandature qui a été signé
en 2011 entre cécile duflot et martine
aubry qui était alors un numéro un du ps
de jeu le jeu je n'avais pas répondu
mais j'ai perçu comme un accent de
sincérité france que j'ai dit voilà
est-ce que effectivement françois
hollande est victime de cet accord
électoral et martine aubry en son temps
est passé avec les écologistes
on peut aussi a contrario par rapport ce
que ce sourire que j'exprimais on peut
aussi considérer je le fait que l'accord
avec les écologistes a permis la
victoire parce qu'il faut d'abord
rassembler c'est toujours la logique
électorale elle n'a pas changé il faut
d'abord rassembler son camp
ensuite rassembler la gauche pour les
gens de gauche bien évidemment et donc
les écologistes en font partie
incontestablement ils ont leur place
dans le gouvernement mais à condition de
respecter eux aussi une sorte de
discipline collective qui fait qui peut
leur imposer le respect de la discipline
qui qui qui qui qui qui ne fait pas son
job la scène chef de l'état c'est le
premier ministre
non mais c'est là je parle et pas
uniquement du gouvernement je parlais à
l'intérieur de leur ai dis donc
voilà c'est leur responsabilité c'est
pour ça que je les appelle à prendre ses
responsabilités là je reviens à manuel
valls
à droite on à nicolas sarkozy qui a fait
campagne qui fait encore campagne en
disant qu'il est le seul rempart contre
le front national en vue des élections
des prochaines municipales est ce que
vous pensez que manuel valls peut-être
celui qui se rabiboche avec un électorat
qui pourraient être tentés par le vote
front national
son travail de ministre est bien fait il
le fait de manière professionnelle dans
un cadre républicain donc c'est un atout
incontestable pour la gauche mais moi je
continue garantie pour limiter la casse
non pourquoi voulez-vous limiter la
casse j'ai dit tout à l'heure à michel
conscient que je considère au contraire
que le meilleur moyen pour nous de de
gagner des municipalités ou de conserver
nos municipalités c'est le travail de
nos élus locaux et s'ils peuvent
s'appuyer sur le travail national fait
par manuel valls tant mieux et c'est ce
qui se produira mais la victoire 6 1
victoire aux municipales ou le maintien
de nos positions ce qui serait déjà bien
le nombre de municipalités que nous
avons elle ne sera pas due uniquement
manuel maintient une multitude de
facteurs le premier des facteurs sur le
travail des élus locaux
c'est le point c'est la qualité du
travail des mères c'est ça qui va être
jugé
c'est ça qu'il faut juger en même temps
c'est fort bien quand ils appliquent la
loi républicaine mais c'est pas facile
pour lui je le dis ici c'est pas facile
pour lui les camps de roms ils sont pas
apparus en 2012 quand nous sommes
arrivés il était là depuis longtemps
ils sont bien souvent enkystée sur le
territoire et donc c'est pas facile de
les démanteler et il faut le faire avec
fermeté comme il le fait mais aussi l
humanité on est que le bilan de la
sécurité mais pas bon avec la
progression de la délinquance ces jeunes
je conteste ces chiffres et vont
complètement je prends tous ces chiffres
je pense que avec les zones de sécurité
prioritaires tout un travail est fait
qui permet des réussites
on a vu des saisies d'armes des saisies
importantes de drogue mais il ya c'est
vrai on a vu un certain mais de la
violence à marseille mais vous avez eu
bien ça c'est l'aspect médiatique des
choses
s'il y avait un peut-être un reproche
mais fait son travail professionnel en
référé manuel m c'est que à force de
venir à chaque fois qu'il ya un meurtre
à marseille on croit qu'il ya plus de
monde que l'année d'avant or la maman il
y avait plus de rebondir et c'est pas
mieux qu'il en est ok ils s'économisent
un petit peu dans ses déplacements paris
marseille ou qui rappelle qu'il y en
avait encore plus l'année d'avant ce qui
n'est pas quand même une garantie en
soit deux victoires parce que ça m'a
toujours de trop bien sûr d'accord merci
carla va arriver pour la dernière partie
de l'émission où il sera notamment
question du cumul des mandats alors on
l'a entendu depuis le succès mission en
france a demandé que l'on serre les
rangs derrière le chef de l'état doit
quand même vous vous distinguez à votre
manière un dossier dans lequel on
retrouve d'ailleurs l'intraitable manuel
valls saint geniès le bar ou de
déshonneur la faute du sénat des
sénateurs qui votent le non-cumul sauf
pour eux c'est peu dire que l'image de
l'institution a été ternie après le vote
où le sur le non cumul des mandats
les sénateurs se sont donné le droit de
cumuler leur mandat avec un mandat
exécutif local contrairement aux députés
une campagne de dénigrement que ne
comprend pas alain gournac pour lui
l'ancrage local c'est ce qui fait la
spécificité du sénat on nous nous sommes
issus du territoire
nous sommes nous respirons la france
tout en ne respirons terrain et c'est
cette respiration qui nous permet
aujourd'hui de ne pas être théorique des
sénateurs partisans du cumul oui mais
par nécessité insiste françois zocchetto
pour lui si le sénat perdre et son
ancrage territorial il serait amené à
disparaître
il servira à rien d'avoir deux chambres
qu'ils soient identiques l'assemblée
nationale si elle était identique au
sénat je vois pas le et réciproquement
je vois pas du tout l'intérêt
donc il faut que le sénat soit
spécifique et qu'il soit le représentant
des terrains
ouah autre grief leurs indemnités les
sénateurs s'en défendent pour le cumuler
les mandats ne veut pas dire cumuler les
revenus dans le texte adopté au sénat
ils ont ajouté un amendement spécifiques
une innovation par rapport au texte voté
à l'assemblée nationale en cas de cumul
les sénateurs ne percevront que leurs
indemnités de parlementaire
une économie selon eux pour l'état du
point de vue de la morale comme du point
de vue des finances
l'économie n'est pas dans le non cumul
et pour montrer encore davantage leur
bonne volonté les sénateurs ont même
proposé de limiter les mandats dans le
temps
un amendement désapprouvée par le
gouvernement et qui a été rejetée on l'a
vu dans une incompréhension totale de la
position des sénateurs par l'opinion
comment vous avez vécu cette période
c'est pas été une période facile parce
que la position que j'ai adoptait une
position de conviction que j'exprimais
il ya fort longtemps parce que je
considère que dans le fonctionnement de
nos institutions
le sénat qui représente les
collectivités territoriales de la
république qui sont élus par des mères
devraient pouvoir ouvrant pouvoir en
gras devrait pouvoir cumuler un mandat
de maire en l'occurrence un mandat
exécutif local et un seul et le faire
même de manière bénévole
parce que je pense que l' expertise
ça peut faire sourire si je voulais être
dans l'air du temps je dirais exactement
le contraire parce que c'est pas ça qui
m'amène de la popularité c'est non on
puisse dire surtout qu'on peut l'être
brocardé facilement donc moi c'est un
combat de conviction pour le
fonctionnement de nos institutions pour
la qualité de la loi
je veux dire pour la qualité de la loi
qui est cette je pense que quand on est
maire quand on sait comment fonctionne
une mairie quand on voit la réalité de
l'application de la loi sur le terrain
et ça on ne le voit pas quand on est
conseiller municipal
quand on le voit en tant que maire et
dénoncé des meilleures lois mais moins
présents parfois parlement mais je pense
que souvent ce sont les élus qui
cumulent qui sont le plus présents
donc vous pouvez rester conseiller
mais c'est parce qu'elles sont sur les
rangs j'étais au cabinet de pierre josse
cote la loi était adoptée en 1983 qui
donne le droit à l'information c'est le
droit à la formation des minorités dans
les conseils
mais c'est pourquoi ton n'est pas dans
l'exécutif d'une collectivité locale
on ne met pas en oeuvre concrètement les
lois et donc ce qui donne cette
expertise c'est le fait de mettre en
oeuvre concrètement les lois quand on ne
sait pas comment on fait pour construire
un logement pour l'enseigné des zones
d'aménagement concerté bien on comprend
des lois qui sont des fois un décalage
avec la réalité elles sont moins
efficaces et cette expertise qui peut
être complétée bien sûr par la position
de l'assemblée c'était ou trancher cette
expertise et les importantes pour faire
des lois qu'ils soient des lois
efficaces
gérard collomb a proposé la semaine
dernière de faire du sénat à un espèce
de bundesrat et une assemblée des élus
locaux à l'allemande
est ce que vous êtes favorable à cette
évolution du sénat à partir du moment où
vous perdez cette spécificité
j'ai pensé à ça c'est un beau débat qui
mériteraient c'est ça que j'ai reproché
au fond finalement à cette loi sur le
cumul c'est qu'elle arrive de manière un
peu excusez moi l'expression un peu
sèche comme ça sans avoir une réflexion
globale
le président du sénat je dois le dire le
président le président du sénat qui est
d'ailleurs à un ami
et je lui affirmer ici jean pierre bel
on soutient plus totale face à des
attaques personnelles dont il a été
l'objet est bien le président du sénat
il a une position sur une conception du
bicamérisme jean pierre gérard collomb
et moi j'avais émis aussi cette idée en
a eu une conception d'un mécanisme est
différente c'est un vrai débat qui
mérite d'être mené
et d'ailleurs moi je proposerai après
tout ça peut-être une réflexion sur les
institutions que nous devrions avoir
quel est le risque pour le sénat je
pense que c'est non seulement ce que je
vais devenir le sénat je pense que se
dit que ça pourrait être une chambre
d'apparatchiks par exemple des choses
quand même sens sans savoir ce que je
regrette c'est que la représentation des
collectivités territoriales ne sera pas
assuré de la même manière par des
sénateurs qui ne seront pas en
responsabilité d'exécutifs locaux on
enlève ou l'avait bien fait de le
signaler vous avez bien fait de le
signaler on enlève la partie cumul des
indemnités qui fait que beaucoup de la
population beaucoup de personnes pensent
que c'est pour cumuler les indemnités
puisque ça sera un mandat bénévole
le mandat exécutif local et puis on
réfléchit au fonctionnement de nos
institutions
est-ce que ça entraînerait la
disparition du sénat je ne le crois pas
je ne le crois pas pour autant il faut
pas non plus forcer le trait mais je
pense que son rôle serait amoindrie dans
la relation vous
vous venez de tenir votre soutien à jean
pierre bel comment vous pouvez
effectivement en ce moment ce contexte
particulier où votre propre majorité
c'est un peu figuration au cénacle
gouvernement ne tient pas compte un peu
de cette majorité de vos taxes ici
d'abord je voudrais dire qu'il ya eu une
campagne de ce qu'on appelle couramment
mais tout le monde comprendra du du
sénat bashing le sénat serait une
assemblée démodé et ses os et ça c'était
parce que sur le cumul on a pris cette
position
on n'a pas découvert dans certains aussi
fondu non pas forcément où je pense
qu'on entend beaucoup de choses qui se
disent très désagréable sur le sénat
c'est pour moi le cas dans les médias
sur l' on a vu qu'ils sont les
associations voient le vote sur les
réseaux sociaux
voilà dans la presse où effectivement
enfin bon peu importe donc moi je
voudrais dire quand même que nous avons
voté des lois qui montre la modernité du
sénat nous avons voté la loi même si ça
fait pas plaisir de le rappeler qui
donne le droit de vote aux étrangers en
situation régulière dans notre pays
après tout l'assemblée peut le faire
aussi maintenant puisque nous l'avons
été et puis nous avons voté le manège
pour tous on a voté donc des lois qui
sont des lois pour pourrait dire comme
ça de modernité bigre importantes sont
aussi retoqué on a vu l'année dernière
pour la loi de finances ici n'est pas
passée la majorité vous le savez très
bien
la majorité sénatoriale n'est pas la
même que la majorité gouvernementale
le groupe communiste qui nous a donné
cette majorité avec les autres groupes
qui nous a donné cette majorité qui a
permis l'élection de jean pierre bel ne
participe pas au gouvernement de la
république au gouvernement de jean marc
ayrault et donc il
il vote comme il l'entend de suivant les
textes et donc il n'ya pas concordance
entre la majorité gouvernementale et la
ferme en cas de figure non je pense que
vous savez si le sénat était gelée dès
jeudi à jean marc ayrault si le sénat
était vraiment dans l'opposition le
gouvernement verrait la difficulté donc
il verrait la difficulté parce que mais
il est prêt il est présent le
gouvernement beaucoup plus qu'il ne
l'était sous françois fillon je crois
pas que françois fillon nous a fait
l'honneur de venir souvent aux questions
d'actualité au sénat
pour marc ayrault le fait j'ai envie de
vous poser la même question que tout à
l'heure à propos des écologistes martine
aubry est ce que vous ne vous sentez pas
lié par cet engagement de françois
hollande sur le non-cumul parce que je
sais une promesse en fait qui a été
arrachée au crédit de la part martine
aubry à l'époque
moi j'ai j'ai dit à françois hollande
j'ai dit à françois hollande que je
n'étais pas d'accord avec cette
proposition que c'était ma conviction
profonde et je lui ai dit d'autant plus
facilement je peux me permettre je sais
pas de dégager ma responsabilité je les
assume et mais je lui ai dit d'autant
plus facilement que je savais que ce
texte ne passerait pas au sénat puisque
y avait pas de majorité pour cela on va
dire un mot du parti socialiste et de
harlem désir c'est vrai qu'on entend
beaucoup les ministres on entend les
parlementaires mais le parti socialiste
lui est assez mu est absent de la scène
politique est ce que vous en veniez
harlem désir à se réveiller sa
manifester un peu plus bas il est
présent il prépare les élections
municipales c'est le rôle du parti
désigne les candidats position dans les
débats
une fonction il le fait de manière plus
discrète
ce qui est vrai c'est que le parti
socialiste a été en quelque sorte et été
avec le départ de du meilleur d'eux les
meilleurs d'entre eux oh
au gouvernement et donc fou qui se
remettre en marche oui mais pas par
plaisir faut que le parti socialiste se
re met en mouvement autour de harlem
désir il ya des secrétaires nationaux où
il faut qu'ils assument leurs
responsabilités tous collectivement et
c'est pas facile parce qu'il n'avait pas
l'habitude de le faire
le virage à droite de françois bayrou
est ce qui vous handicape à dijon où des
élus modem font partie de votre majorité
oui des élus modem font partie de la
majorité à la prochaine
ma démarche et les simples je rassemble
la gauche rassemblée socialiste se
rassemble à gauche et sur la base de mon
programme viennent ceux qui souhaitent
venir donc dans les partis républicains
et donc bien évidemment les les élus
modem centre ile-de-france wab ayrault
avait souhaité me rejoindre sur la base
de notre programme
vous avez tendu la main oui j'ai tout
nouveau en un françois hollande de ne
pas l'avoir fait avec françois bayrou
non ce que je pensais qu'on aurait pu
effectivement peut-être à un moment
prendre plus donné plus de considération
à françois bayrou et que je vois si ça
aurait changé comme je sais pas si ça
aurait changé je peux pas sûr que
c'était le mieux
non mais enfin je pense que quand il ya
quelqu'un qui a appelé à voter pour vous
je pense qu'il faut le considérer voilà
donc des regrets de ses 500 têtes on
aurait pu faire les choses et
transcendante évite l'aspect sable de
son virage à droite toujours dit non non
seulement fausse wallon qui est aussi
assez il est assez grand pour s'assumer
quand on a quand on a des convictions
voilà il d'ailleurs il explique que
maintenant c'est justement parce que
françois hollande est trop à gauche que
il est avec borloo je pense un vrai
centriste françois bayrou c'est un vrai
centriste il n'y en a pas beaucoup des
vrais de vrai c'est à dire c'est ce
qu'il a pratiqué jusqu'à présent est à
droite
il ne veut plus d'alliance ça va changer
on verra ce que font les élus modem à
dijon comme ailleurs
après tout il participe à l'exécutif
municipal s'ils veulent continuer ça
dépend de la semaine dernière eric
doligé sénateur ump avait fait part de
ses instincts meurtriers à l'égard de
françois hollande et de sa bande
c'étaient des paroles publiques 1 lors
des journées parlementaires de l'ump
éric bélanger ne s'est pas excusé est-ce
que vous avez discuté avec lui voulait
avait parlé au téléphone
non je vais j'ai vu avec un peu de
stupéfaction cette déclaration qui peut
être tenus pour des propos j'allais dire
presque d'après banquet pour aider les
choses comme ça mais je voudrais attirer
l'attention de du sénateur doligé sur la
portée de ces propos parce que ça
s'adresse bien souvent l'ensemble la
population quand ils sont repris
publiquement il ya des esprits faibles
et ça peut avoir un impact sur des
esprits faibles
je trouve intolérable ce type de propos
dans la démocratie apaisée que nous
souhaitons vous souhaite au sénat et
ailleurs eh bien il faut se respecter
puis je dirai au sénateur doligé qui va
falloir qu'il prenne son mal en patience
parce que on est là pour cinq ans et
donc s'il en est à vouloir avoir des
instincts meurtriers au bout d'un an et
demi qu'est ce qu'il faut au moins
quatre ans donc je l'appelle à réunir
les choses tout à fait jambes un peu
plus rangé ses kalachnikov maintenant
mais jean-louis il est dit que c'était
de l'humour on achète pas mal changé
l'humour
doligé c'était c'était plus que
borderline
la réaction de godasses j'avais pas vu
mais moi j'aime l'humour je le dis à
jean claude gaudin
merci d'avoir été avec nous cette
semaine en français merci michel bonsoir
à tous et à très vite